well you mentioned culture over the last
70 years and I really wanna to unpack
this in a little more detail and how it
applies to children especially now the
conspicuous consumption era has its
everywhere now yeah I'm your and you're
in your book this the story that Moe
teaches you about is that very
financially successful and oh you
answered a question why was nothing to
us man can I get them in so and so
financially successful and then the
process of wanting to you see and you're
in Dubai Dubai how many I don't know how
many of you have been to Dubai but when
you're in Dubai you see extraordinary
wealth extraordinary wealth in Dubai and
you you go I'm gonna with click with a
couple clicks I'm gonna buy a Rolls
Royce and the moment the rules of rice
are landed you weren't any happier and
this sort of consumptive process of I
don't wear jewelry and I don't want to
wear jewelry I don't like the vibe other
people like the vibe and they can they
can choose that to be their vibe but
there is a certain reason for that and I
think that if there is some sort of a
process of consumption that we get used
to once you get a one-bedroom apartment
you want a 2-bedroom apartment then you
want three then you want a house and you
want two cars not just one car so what
what do we do because so much of the
culture around us is pushing these
milestones in our face
what do we what do we do in return you
find out what you really want how many
of us actually spend time to introspect
and say okay that didn't work the idea
of consuming so much is because we have
been taught that material possessions
are gonna make us happy so you buy a car
and for somewhere around 20 to 70
seconds you go like I made it right and
then you sit behind the wheel and
regardless of what car it is what do you
look at you look at the road right
it doesn't really matter at all which
car you are in unless it serves your ego
right which basically is the reason why
people buy expensive cars
it's like to tell the rest of the world
that you made it now I will tell you
hands down if you really have made it
you will realize that this urge goes
away it's like and you know unless you
haven't made it and so you're trying to
lie to the world and I might as well
tell you
save your money until you make it right
but that's not the point the point is
we're consuming because of because of a
vicious circle
we buy something it gives us that jolt
of happiness for 20 seconds and then it
goes away and we start to say instead of
saying that whatever it is that we
bought has no inherent value of
happiness in it we say RB it's because
we didn't buy the right one right if I
buy a better car I'll probably find
happiness there right so you buy a
better car and then you just get that
jolt for 60 seconds and then you go like
ah it went away because it's not red if
I bought it in red I would be happier
right and you keep chasing and chasing
surprisingly stupid enough to never stop
and say is happiness not found in cars
like seriously when I was a child lying
on my back I didn't have a car and I was
happy right so is happiness not found it
there
hmm and when you make that just little
pause to think hmm suddenly you realize
what it is that's not serving you in
life